well this is the episode that you've all
been waiting for
i thought for today's episode we could
go and visit a building
it's a really nice beautiful day so i
wanted to go and visit
a arthur erickson building
so arthur erickson is probably one of
the most
influential canadian architects
um especially here in the west coast
he's built
buildings like the sfu camp is the
this building that we're in right now
the canadian embassy in the states
roy thompson concert hall all of his
buildings are very well
integrated into the landscape he
he studied in greece and italy
and uh he learned how to contextualize
his buildings so if you look at um like
in vancouver we have a lot of
hills going up and down so if you look
at the stairs
that have the integrated ramps that's
his way of
integrating the building into the
landscape so that there's a seamless
connection between the building and the
street
and he even brings the landscape into
the buildings i mean that's one of the
traits of brutalist buildings
like if you see this building here
you can see that the planters
just go right into the building today i
wanted to visit
one of his lesser-known projects
it's called the waterfall building it's
in granville island so the story of his
career is that he was on a
really good trajectory for a long time
he built all these significant projects
and i think there were a couple projects
that people were not that into
so one of them was the roy thompson hall
i think it got a lot of slack because
the acoustics and that space was not
that great
he was obviously really known for his
use of concrete
i think he called it the marble of his
time
after the construction of a couple of
his
brutalist project people started
realizing that concrete
actually weathers and ages really badly
and then so that was all coupled with
the new style emerging like the new
pose-modernist
like frank gehry styles where they're
the buildings are not really like
part of the context the waterfall
building it was commissioned by
bob rennie um who's like a big developer
here in vancouver and so this was one of
the buildings that
kind of brought his reputation back up i
think it'll be interesting
[Music]
so this building was designed in 1996
and i think it was completed in the
early 2000s
and the concept was basically to
create a sense of community spirit
within these apartments and
he achieved this through this courtyard
so there's four apartment blocks that's
around the courtyard so
there's this one this one
and this one and there's one
right in front that you guys can't see
and there's also this weird
pyramid-shaped
art gallery which is
now used for wedding stuff
and i think the most incredible part of
this
building this courtyard experience is
this waterfall
apparently it was created to
separate the streets from the courtyard
acoustically and this
this curve here
it kind of acts as a sundial
so depending on what time of day or
what season you come to see the
courtyard
the sun angle will change ever so
slightly
[Music]
so these are some of the other functions
there's a hair salon
and a marijuana dispensary and this
was designed as a art gallery but
looks like it's being used for wedding
services now
and the rest of it is basically um
live work studios for artists and
i've only been to one of them once
and it was really really beautiful it's
like
16 foot tall faces like
light from both directions i think all
the units are
interlocking so you get sun exposure
from both
both directions um but yeah they all
have like exposed concrete and exposed
steel on the inside
you